CAVE TO OCASIO-CORTEZ?
JOINING US NOW, CONGRESSMAN
DEVIN NUNES AND THE FREEDOM
CAUCUS CHAIRMAN MARK MEADOWS.
I'VE GOT TO SAY THIS ABOUT
JIM JORDAN, DEVIN NUNES, THE
FRESHMAN IS OVERLY AMBITIOUS BUT
A GOOD GUY AND HE'S DONE A GREAT
JOB.
WITHOUT YOU GUYS BEHIND THE
SCENES, WE HAVE NOW SEEN THESE
CLOSED-DOOR TESTIMONIES.
WE WOULD NOT BE HERE AND THIS
WOULD LIKELY HAVE GOTTEN AWAY
WITH.
CONGRESSMAN DEVIN NUNES A
SPECIAL APPLAUSE TO YOU FOR THAT
SPEECH, PROBABLY RIGHT UP THERE
WITH LINDSEY GRAHAM'S SPEECH ON
THE DAY OF THE BRETT KAVANAUGH
HEARINGS.
>> WHAT WAS AMAZING TO ME THAT A
LOT OF PEOPLE DIDN'T PAY
ATTENTION TO, THERE WERE TWO
RETIRED FBI AGENTS ON THE
WITNESS TABLE ALONG WITH
ANDY McCARTHY WHO APPEARS ON
YOUR SHOW AND OTHERS.
WHAT I WAS AMAZED THAT WAS THE
LACK OF CONCERN BY THESE FORMER
FBI AGENTS, ONE OF THEM
PETER STRZOK USED TO WORK FOR
AND THEY SERVE THEIR COUNTRY AND
I'M SURE THEY DID A GREAT JOB.
I BROUGHT UP THE FACT THAT WE
PROBABLY SHOULDN'T BE USING
COUNTERINTELLIGENCE CAPABILITIES
IN THIS COUNTRY TO TARGET A
POLITICAL CAMPAIGN, THEY JUST
SAT THERE.
IT WAS ALMOST AS THOUGH THEY HAD
BEEN COACHED BY THE DEMOCRATS TO
NOT SAY ANYTHING BAD ABOUT THE
COUNTERINTELLIGENCE
INVESTIGATION THAT IT OCCURRED.
IF THAT'S THE ATTITUDE, I WILL
TELL YOU IF THAT ATTITUDE
PERMEATED THROUGHOUT THE
COUNTERINTELLIGENCE CAPABILITIES
AND IF RETIRED FBI AGENTS THINK
IT'S OKAY TO USE
COUNTERINTELLIGENCE AGAINST
POLITICAL CAMPAIGNS, I THINK
WE'VE GONE A LONG WAY IN THIS
COUNTRY.
THAT USED TO BE DEMOCRATS WHO
DIDN'T SUPPORT THE
COUNTERINTELLIGENCE BECAUSE THEY
THOUGHT THEY WERE SPYING ON
CAMPAIGNS.
THEY TOOK THEM OVER, THEY
CORRUPTED THE WHOLE THING AND IT
SEEMS LIKE THAT IS THE ATTITUDE
THROUGHOUT THE FBI FOR MOST OF
THE FORMER OFFICIALS.
>> Sean: IT WAS A POWERFUL
SPEECH YOU GAVE TODAY.
AND I MEAN THIS AS THE BIGGEST
COMPLIMENT TO CONGRESSMAN
MEADOWS AND I WANT EVERYONE TO
UNDERSTAND, WHAT YOU AND
JIM JORDAN IN PARTICULAR DID
BEHIND CLOSED DOORS NOW THAT WE
ARE GETTING THOSE TRANSCRIPTS,
YOU ARE ASKING THE RIGHT
QUESTIONS, THE HARDEST
QUESTIONS, THE INFORMED
QUESTIONS AND FORWARD THINKING
QUESTIONS KNOWING WHAT THE TRUTH
WOULD EVENTUALLY BE AND COME OUT
AS.
YOUR REACTION TO ALL OF THESE
EVENTS.
>> I CAN TELL YOU DEVIN NUNES
HAS DONE AN UNBELIEVABLE JOB AND
ACTUALLY WE HAVE HAD TWO
DIFFERENT CAMPS, HE HAS SEEN
MUCH OF A CLASSIFIED, JIM JORDAN
AND I HAVE NOT.
WE HAVE BEEN ABLE TO WORK
TOGETHER IN A WAY THAT IS ABOUT
TRANSPARENCY FOR THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
HERE'S THE THING THAT DAWNED ON
ME TODAY, YOU HAD ANOTHER
MUELLER HEARING HERE, WHY WAS IT
OPEN?
BECAUSE THEY WANTED TO TRY TO
RESURRECT THE WHOLE MUELLER
NARRATIVE INTO THEIR BEST TO
MAKE SURE THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
ARE ENGAGED BUT THE TRUTH OF THE
MATTER IS THEY DIDN'T GET THE
RESULT THEY WANTED.
THERE WAS THE IF AT FIRST YOU
DON'T SUCCEED, TRY, TRY AGAIN,
THEY HAVE TRIED AND TRIED AGAIN
AND THEY WILL CONTINUE TO TRY
BUT THE PROBLEM IS THEY KNOW THE
TRUTH.
EVEN SOME OF THE WITNESSES TODAY
HERE ON CAPITOL HILL, THEY ARE
SUPPOSED TO BE EXPERTS.
THEY HAVEN'T EVEN READ TO THE
STEELE DOSSIER, THAT'S HOW NOT
CREDIBLE THAT WAS.
>> Sean: HOW ARE WE TO
INTERPRET THIS "NEW YORK TIMES"
NEWS TONIGHT, DO BOTH OF YOU
BELIEVE AS I THINK I'M READING
AND INTERPRETING, I ALWAYS ASK
BOTH OF YOU ONE QUESTION,
NEITHER ONE OF YOU WOULD LEAK
THE WAY I WANTED YOU TO --
YOU'RE LAUGHING, WHAT'S THE
QUESTION?
AM I OVER THE TARGET?
AM I OVER THE TARGET AND
THINKING COUNTRIES LIKE ITALY,
ALLIED COUNTRIES, GREAT BRITAIN
AND AUSTRALIA WERE OUTSOURCED
INTELLIGENCE GATHERING TO
CIRCUMVENT AMERICAN LAWS?
>> I THINK WHAT WE DON'T KNOW
YET AS WE DON'T KNOW WHO JOSEPH
MISSIVE WAS WORKING FOR, HE WAS
IN ITALY, THAT BRINGS UP -- HE
COULD BE PART OF THE ITALIAN
GOVERNMENT, HE COULD BE A
BRITISH ASSET BECAUSE HE ALSO
LIVED IN LONDON.
IT COULD BE POSSIBLE THAT HE WAS
WORKING FOR FUSION GPS OR AN
OPERATION LIKE FUSION GPS
THROUGH CHRISTOPHER STEELE.
WHAT WE DON'T KNOW AT THE HEART
OF THIS IS WHERE TO THE CLINTON
CAMPAIGN DIRTY OPERATION THAT
WAS RUN BY FUSION GPS AND THE
FBI -- THEY WERE ON PARALLEL
TRACKS.
WHEN DID THOSE MERGE, THAT IS
WHAT MYSELF AND MARK MEADOWS
HAVE BEEN TRYING TO FIGURE OUT
FOR A LONG TIME AND HOPEFULLY
THAT IS WHAT THE U.S. ATTORNEY
OUT OF CONNECTICUT IS GOING TO
GET TO THE BOTTOM OF.
WE HAVE A RIGHT TO KNOW WHAT
COUNTRIES WERE INVOLVED IN THIS.
>> WE ARE GETTING A LOT OF
WHISTLE-BLOWERS, PRIMARILY THEY
ARE COMING FORWARD BECAUSE THEY
BELIEVE ATTORNEY GENERAL
BILL BARR AND JOHN DURHAM ARE
WILLING TO GET TO THE BOTTOM OF
IT.
PEOPLE WHO PERHAPS WERE AFRAID
UNDER PREVIOUS LEADERSHIP TO
ACTUALLY SAY WE KNEW THIS WAS
WRONG, THEY ARE COMING FORWARD
NOW.
WHEN WE LOOK AT INTELLIGENCE, WE
KNOW THE INTELLIGENCE COMMUNITY
SHARES A LOT OF INFORMATION.
WHAT DEVIN NUNES KNOWS,
JIM JORDAN, MARK MEADOWS AND
OTHERS WHO HAVE BEEN INVOLVED,
THE STEELE DOSSIER,
CHRISTOPHER STEELE, HIS DOSSIER
NOT ONLY DOESN'T HAVE HIS HIS
ORIGINS WITH FUSION GPS AND THE
DEMOCRATIC NATIONAL COMMITTEE,
OTHER PLAYERS WHO ARE CONNECTED.
SIDNEY BLUMENTHAL AND THEY WERE
SHOPPING IT TO EVERY MEDIA
OUTLET THEY POSSIBLY COULD AND
THE FBI KNEW IT.
THE FBI KNEW IT PRIOR TO THAT
FIRST FISA AND HERE THEY ARE
USING IT AS CREDIBLE INFORMATION
FOR A FISA APPLICATION?
I THINK THAT'S TOTALLY WRONG.
>> Sean: LET ME ASK YOU THE
BOTH SAME EXIT QUESTION, MOST
PEOPLE ARE ASKING ME WHEN ARE
THEY GOING TO BE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE?
WHAT DO YOU SEE IN THE FUTURE,
DEVIN NUNES, YOU KNOW A WHOLE
LOT MORE THAN I DO, WHERE DO YOU
SEE THIS GOING AND WHO WOULD YOU
NOT WANT TO BE TONIGHT IN TERMS
OF PUTTING YOUR HEAD DOWN ON A
PILLOW FOR A PEACEFUL NIGHT'S
SLEEP.
>> IF YOU OR ANY OF THE FORMER
PEOPLE AT THE FBI IN THOSE
FAMOUS TEXT MESSAGES THAT
MARKETED SUCH A GOOD JOB OF
GETTING TO THE BOTTOM OF COME OF
THOSE PEOPLE ALL THINK I HAVE TO
CONCERNED.
IF YOU LOOK AT THE DIRTY
OPERATIONS ARMS OF THE CLINTON
CAMPAIGN, ULTIMATELY THAT
STEELE DOSSIER PERMEATED ALL THE
WAY THROUGH TO THE SPECIAL
COUNSEL AND I'LL CLOSE WITH THIS
TONIGHT.
I WAS FINALLY ABLE TO SEE THE
SCOPE OF MEMO AND I HAD THESE
CONCERNS THAT IT WAS BASED UPON
THE STEELE DOSSIER AND I CAN'T
TALK ABOUT WHAT WAS IN THERE BUT
WE KNOW FROM THE MUELLER REPORT
OR FROM WHAT JUDGE SULLIVAN PUT
OUT, WE KNOW IT WAS LARGELY
BASED ON THE STEELE DOSSIER.
>> Sean: THE BULK OF THE
INFORMATION CAME FROM THAT.
LAST WORD, MARK.
>> PEOPLE NEED TO GO TO JAIL,
PEOPLE NEED TO BE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE AND I BELIEVE
INDICTMENTS ARE ON THEIR WAY.
>> Sean: I WANT TO THANK YOU
BOTH, THESE TWO GUYS, WE